aquí tenemos dos moléculas
este es el peróxido de hidrógeno se
llama peróxido por este enlace oxígeno
oxígeno y por acá tenemos de fluoruro de
oxígeno en donde el oxígeno está unido a
dos átomos de flúor
me gustaría que pausa en el vídeo y usen
esta tabla de los elementos en donde nos
dicen la electro negatividad estas
electro negatividades están basadas en
la escala de polling por el famoso
bioquímico linus pauling piensen en los
estados de oxidación o números de
oxidación en estas moléculas pausa en el
vídeo
voy a suponer que ya trataron de
averiguarlo y seguramente encontraron
algo muy interesante habíamos dicho que
sólo faltan dos electrones de valencia
para que el oxígeno logre llenar su capa
electrónica y como es muy electro
negativo el oxígeno generalmente toma
electrones de otros elementos
generalmente dos electrones
lo que le da un estado de oxidación o
número de oxidación dos negativos están
electro negativo que generalmente oxida
a otros elementos y es por eso que a
este fenómeno se le llama oxidación pero
aquí lo interesante es que el oxígeno
está unido a algo tan electro negativo
como a sí mismo y por supuesto el
peróxido de hidrógeno está unido al
hidrógeno pero también está unido a otro
oxígeno obviamente estos dos serán igual
de electro negativos entonces cuáles son
los estados de oxidación o los números
de oxidación para este caso
bueno el hidrógeno como es el menos
electro negativo tendrá una carga
parcial positiva porque los electrones
pasarán más tiempo cerca de este oxígeno
pero cuando hablamos de estados de
oxidación no nos importan las cargas
parciales hay que imaginar qué
los enlaces covalentes son enlaces
iónicos supongamos enlaces iónicos si
éstos fueran en la sesión y cause que
pasaría bueno si tenemos que dejarle
estos electrones a alguien se los
daríamos al oxígeno denle los electrones
al oxígeno eso le dará un estado de
oxidación 1 negativo y si le quitamos
estos electrones al hidrógeno entonces
tiene un estado de oxidación 1 positivo
y lo mismo pasará con este oxígeno y
este hidrógeno es algo fascinante porque
este es un ejemplo en donde el oxígeno
tiene un estado de oxidación que no es 2
negativo sino más bien uno negativo es
realmente interesante y se vuelve cada
vez más interesante con el de fluoruro
de oxígeno porque él
es el único elemento en toda la tabla
que es más electro negativo que el
oxígeno
este es un enlace covalente pero si
suponemos enlaces iónicos y tuviéramos
que dejarle los electrones a algunos de
estos átomos se los daríamos al flúor
entonces el flúor cada uno tiene un
estado de oxidación uno negativo y el
oxígeno imagínense esto es una locura
para el oxígeno el estado de oxidación
para el oxígeno que está donando estos
electrones es 2 positivo
recuerden que cuando se escribe el
estado de oxidación como súper índice se
acostumbre escribir el signo después del
número tiene un estado de oxidación 2
positivo el oxígeno que
tanto le gusta oxidar a otros ha sido
oxidado por el flúor este ha sido un
ejemplo muy dramático de como algo puede
desviarse del estado de oxidación o
número de oxidación típico en la mayoría
de las moléculas el oxígeno tiene un
estado de oxidación o número de
oxidación 2 negativo a menos de que esté
unido a otro oxígeno o al flúor que es
el único elemento más electro negativo
que el oxígeno